في تاريخ المونديال الطويل وعلى مدار 26
نسخه سابقه ثلاثه فقط عرفوا طريقه ذهبي
لاعبين ومدربين
اسطوره المانيا
من كاس العالم الاولى في مونديال انجلترا
عام
1966 وخسر النهائيه امام اصحاب الارض في
مشاركته الثانيه بالمكسيك عام 1970 حل
الالماني الثالثه
ليقود الماكينات للفوز بامم اوروبا عام
1972 ثم بالمونديال الذي استضافته المانيا
عام
1974 ويرفع كاس العالم للمره الثانيه
لبلاده بعد الفوز على الطواحين الهولنديه
بهدفين لهف
القيصر الالماني تولى تدريب منتخب بلاده
في مونديال
1986 ووصل به الى المباراه النهائيه التي
خسرها امام الارجنتين بقياده الاسطوره
مارادونا وفي النسخه التاليه في ايطاليا
تكرر النهائي بين المانيا والارجنتين لكن
المانشاف تطبيق قياده باكينج باودر حسمه
هذه المره بهدف نظيف
بعد فشلها في التاهل لنسختين متتاليتين
شاركت فرنسا في مونديال
1998 بصفتها البلد المستضيف تغلب
وزيدان ورفاقهما على البرازيل في المباراه
النهائيه ليحصد اللقب الاول للديوك
اعتزلت عام 2001
وخادمه
ثقل بها مهاراته وتولى مهمه تدريب منتخب
بلاده في وقت نصيب فرنسا كانت خرجت من
مونديال 2010 من دوري المجموعات ثم اخفقت
في يورو 2012 اعاده الشراء البريقه للديوك
فوصل للنهائي الامم الاوروبيه عام 2016
لكنه خسيره لصالح البرتغال بهدف في الوقت
الاضافي في مونديال روسيا 2018 تمكن من
تحقيق اللقب الثاني لبلاده على كرواتيا
باربعه اهداف لهدفين ده شوق لديه الفرصه
لتحقيق انجاز اكبر اذ يقود فرنسا في
مونديال قطر سعيا وراء اللقب الثالث
[موسيقى]
في مونديال
1058 بالسويد دكه البرازيل بقياده ساغالو
وبيلي شباك فرنسا ب 5 اهداف لهدفين في نصف
نهائي قبل ان تكتسح اصحاب الارض بنفس
النتيجه لتحصد لقبها الاول وتصبح اولا
منتخب يفوز بالمونديال خارج قارته في
النسخه التاليه كرر ورفاقها الانجاز على
ارض تشيلي على حساب تشيكوسلوفاكيا واضاف
اللقب الثاني له ولدي
خدما سيره تدريبيه بعد اعتزاله محققا بعض
الالقاب المحليه قبل ان يعود مدربا لمنتخب
سوا هذه المره قاد زانو الفريق البرازيلي
في مونديال المكسيك عام 1970 من خلال
تشكيله بعض رفاقه في اللعب وبينهم باليه
نجح في حصن اللقب الثالث بجداره في ست
مباريات لم يدق فيها طعم التعادل او
الهزيمه لم تتوقف مسيره الاسطوره ففي عام
1994 عاما
[موسيقى]